malaise que l'on dit c'est toujours au
mois d'août que les choses au moins ça
met une sélection par l'argent
uniquement les gens qui ont les moyens
de rouler roulent ont toujours bien
chaud parce qu'ils sont des gars que
nous pensons l'année prochaine
utilisez le
donc déjà assez changé ma façon de
conduire
j'ai conduit beaucoup plus lentement
quand on parle
en vacances alors pour arriver au bout
faut bien prendre de chance on obligé on
n'y peut rien
bonsoir c'était donc cette nuit la nuit
du 4 août vous souvenez peut-être de ce
chapitre de nos livres d'histoire la
nuit leur révolution 1789 l'abolition
des privilèges des nobles et bien plus
prosaïquement pour les automobilistes de
la nuit du 4 août marque simplement le
temps où l'essence franchi la barre des
3 francs 300 0 5 litre de super de pise
erreur de francs 84 d'ordinaire le fioul
domestique à 1 franc 19
est il besoin de le rappeler alors nous
avons voulu savoir quelles étaient les
premières réflexions des automobilistes
qui ont fait le plein après minuit vous
avez entendu j'ai lu dans plusieurs
revues que les économistes estiment
généralement que la demande resterait la
même temps que les sens serait à moins
de 5 francs je leur laisse la
responsabilité de leurs propos
la hausse de l'électricité annoncé ces
jours derniers sera effective elle à
partir de lundi cet ennemi pour cent de
plus en moyenne le pétrole encore lui
cette fois alerte à la marée noire aux
etats-unis
la nappe de pétrole qui s'échappe du
golfe du mexique depuis deux mois
mena sérieux exane est là bas on se
mobilise pour faire face à la
catastrophe
le texas apprête à affronter à son tour
la plus grande marée noire que l'on ait
jamais connu une nappe qui atteint 600
km de long et qui est ce soir après
avoir souillé les plages du mexique
ces images aériennes vous montre les
quantités énormes de pétrole qui ont
déjà atteint la côte mexicaine
provoquant des dommages écologiques
inestimable notamment pour la pêche
les prises de crever de 50%
250 millions de tonnes d'eau déversées
mythique 63 jours après que le puits de
ixtoc 1 est explosé sur le puits même
5000 tonnes par jour continuer à jaillir
du fond de la mer provoquant ce
gigantesque bouillonnement de fla
à
aujourd'hui encore personne ne sait
comment éteindre le puits les prévisions
officielles sont que l'éruption pourrait
durer encore six mois déjà à
l'embouchure du rio grande et ici à la
frontière entre le mexique et des états
unis
les premières nappes isolées sont
apparus et le texas se mobilisent ce
soir pour une bataille écologique sans
doute perdu d'avancé disent les experts
tant la lutte sera inégale iran pas de
surprise des élections pour l'assemblée
constituante vos données une large
victoire au candidat de l'ayatollah
khomeini en fait ce n'est pas forcément
leur et c'est la façon dont s'est
déroulé le scrutin
il était à peu près à l'image du pays
chaotique il ya eu des irrégularités
dans la campagne et dans le scrutin
l'opposition insiste sur un taux
d'abstention important italie ça y est
le démocrate-chrétien francesco possible
mais un gouvernement un gouvernement
composé de démocrates chrétiens de
sociaux des deux libéraux l'italie était
en crise politique depuis six mois et
monsieur peu sig a été la quatrième
personnalité pressentie pour former un
cabinet reste à savoir s'il sera bien
accepté par le parlement
et s'il n'y aura pas de surprise de
dernière minute comme la dernière fois
le président égyptien anouar el sadate
semble se désintéresser voir
volontairement de plus en plus du monde
arabe
c'est l'impression qu'il a donné aux
observateurs dans le discours qu'il a
prononcé hier soir au caire espagne un
garde civil tué ce matin au pays basque
une rafale de mitraillette par deux
inconnus
on serait tenté de dire le terrorisme
ordinaire depuis le début de l'année 95
personnes dont quarante et un policier
ont été tués en espagne hanoi serait
prêt à accepter une solution politique
au cambodge excluant le retour des
khmers rouges de pol pot
ce qui veut dire que le vietnam ne
serait pas opposé à un retour du prince
norodom sihanouk dont se rendraient en
france dans quelques semaines le
gouvernement français ayant donné des
instructions pour qu'un visa lui soit
accordé
norodom sihanouk se trouve actuellement
en corée du nord d'autre part le mien
s'est engagé à prendre des mesures pour
stopper l'exode des réfugiés du vietnam
vers les pays du sud est asiatique
il est évident que tout ce qui a été dit
et fait autour des réfugiés n'est pas
étranger un possible déblocage de la
situation dans cette région avec le
témoignage que nous allons vous
présenter maintenant un témoignage assez
exceptionnel nous ajoutons une nouvelle
pièce au dossier des réfugiés une équipe
d'antenne 2 avec jean-claude de la
tramblais s'est rendu dans un camp en
thaïlande et elle a rencontré l'homme
que vous allez entendre un cambodgien
qui raconte ce qu'il a vu lorsque les
khmers rouges étaient encore à phnom
penh
c'est un témoignage très dur que nous
vous présentons comme je le répète comme
une nouvelle pièce à mettre dans ce
dossier mais avant de l'écouter
reparlons en général des réfugiés afin
de s'y retrouver
c'est peut-être le plus grand exode
forcé de l'histoire d'après la
croix-rouge plus de trois millions et
demi de personnes ont fui la péninsule
indochinoise les réfugiés quittent le
vietnam surtout l'ancien sud vietnam
ainsi que le laos et le cambodge
les vietnamiens surtout ceux qui ne sont
pas d'origine chinoise s'enfuit par mer
vers la malaisie la thaïlande et
l'indonésie
les laotiens eu traversent la frontière
pour se réfugier en thaïlande comme les
khmers c'est à dire les cambodgiens leur
cas est particulièrement atroces après
le véritable génocide des khmers rouges
l'invasion vietnamienne a déclenché une
deuxième vague de réfugiés fuyant vers
les camps de la thaïlande
ils sont dix sept mille thomert réfugiés
dans les camps thaïlandais à la
frontière qu'en mode
c'est là à myroutes que nous avons
recueilli le témoignage de monsieur
klaus a 58 ans sous le régime d'une
france est un homme fêtait la mort
député ensuite vice président de
l'assemblée nationale que mr en 65 et 66
au repos et
était arrivé et commis des atrocités
beaucoup d'atrocités au cambodge
parmi la population sur 7 millions
d'habitants
ils ont massacré plus de la moitié gelé
moi même de mes propres yeux les
réservoirs pour enfouir les cadavres
qu'ils ont tués ils ont assassiné pour
les hommes les ont coupé les victimes en
plusieurs morceaux moindre contradiction
au moindre in observance des règles
édictées par aux dames les gens les
mains liées derrière le dos elle était
avec en maths ans sur la tête
parlez nous maintenant votre voyage de
bata borg jusqu'au camp ici je fais
quelle distance à agir dans le sens 100
km de matam ans environ et que vous avez
fait en quatre jours ce que j'ai fait en
quatre jours jouer nuit aux marchands du
100 ma chambre j'étais obligé d'éviter
la rencontre des vietnamiens les khmers
rouges
et malheureusement les bandes et nous
couper la route nous confisquer tous que
nous procédions et j'étais venu en terre
thaïlandaise avec seulement une veste
et des bandits de quelle nationalité des
bondi de quelle nationalité
les bandes et se commander des
nationalités talent days en général mais
il faut arriver en thaïlande nous avons
entendu dire que voilà les thaïlandais
ne voulez pas regarder les étrangers
allaient aux réfugiés chez eux
c'est pour ça que tout le monde dans la
voir leurs espoirs erreur le monde les
bras
cet espoir il le met entre les mains de
la mission du comité national d'entre
aide aux réfugiés
cette mission avec des effectifs
modesque établi des fiches définit les
liens de parenté et tente de
reconstituer des familles dont les
membres sont disséminés dans différents
ou bien sont déjà arrivés en france
arrivé à me trouver la relation de
travail entre ce monsieur cette madame
est celle ci
et vous-même vers quel pays vous voulez
vous vous dirigez moi même comme je
parle assez passablement le français
j'aime la france je veux demander
l'hospitalité de la france parce que je
savais que la france tant penarol et
humanitaire est aussi bien les états
unis ses yeux qu'ils soient vieux vous
jeunes ont vu beaucoup d'autres cités
qui leur sera difficile d'oublier et ce
peuple qui a toujours le sourire montre
une grande pudeur de sentiments chacun
tente maintenant de s'habituer à sa
nouvelle vie de réfugié de laquelle la
peur et la méfiance n'ont pas totalement
disparu
voilà donc pour ce témoignage demain
suite du reportage de jean claude
delattre en bus en thaïlande avec une
visite de ce camp de réfugiés d'où vous
parler monsieur ndao stars de demain
donc dans le journal de 20h la france et
la roumanie sont d'accord pour la
réunion d'une conférence sur le
désarmement en europe y participeraient
tous les états signataires de l'acte
d'helsinki c'est ce qu'on peut lire dans
la communication qui a été publié après
la visite du ministre roumain des
affaires étrangères en france qui s'est
entretenu avec monsieur jean françois
poncet pour monsieur yvon bourges le
ministre de la défense l'augmentation du
budget militaire de 15% ne veut pas dire
que la france entend jouer un rôle de
gendarme dans certaines parties du monde
monsieur bourges qui était l'invité de
samedi et nuit transmis de dinars dont
monsieur bourges est justement le nerf a
expliqué que le gouvernement avait
simplement voulu réaliser le programme
militaire votée par le parlement qui
avait subi un certain retard l'an
dernier pour le ministre la défense ce
budget ne représente pas un poids
excessif pour le p
le budget de la défense ne représente
pas un poids excessif pour notre pays
nous sommes tout à fait dans les mesures
comparables à des pays comparables au
nord comme par exemple la république
fédérale d'allemagne et même nous
consacrons moins que la grande bretagne
par rapport au produit intérieur brut en
1979 nous sont consacrant 3 67 % du
produit intérieur
l'année prochaine nous serons autour de
3 84 3 85 c'est vous dire par conséquent
que c'est une progression raisonnable et
que c'est une charge supportable car le
gouvernement a eu le souci de faire en
sorte qu'elle ne soit pas incompatible
avec les autres objectifs de
développement économique de progrès
social que nous poursuivons élections
cantonales suite ne soyez pas étonnés
oui on vote demain dans le conte ans
dans le canton des vans en ardèche le
deuxième tour ayant été invalidée
c'est une élection intéressante car de
son résultat dépend la couleur du
conseil général de l'ardèche majorité ou
opposition pour l'instant il ya autant
de conseillers d'un côté que de l'autre
vous êtes nombreux à vous intéresser à
la france et à ses régions nous l'avons
bien vu avec le grand succès de la série
quelle france
fusé dans l'émission question de temps
et bien lundi prochain vous avez rendez
vous avec le dernier numéro de cette
série consacrée à la gironde
découverte de la gironde avec ses
habitants et ses six beaux paysages
question de temps donc lundi à 21h cas
il ya ceux qui partent en vacances il y
a ceux qui ne partent pas nous vous en
avons parlé
et puis il ya ceux qui partent pour la
première fois en vacances par exemple
ces petits français garçons et filles
qui ont pris le train ces jours ci pour
les pays bas afin d'y être accueillis
par des familles néerlandaises leur
séjour a été mis sur pied par le secours
populaire français
il s'agit donc d'enfants déshérités à
l'adouber ski et bernard berliet ont
suivi deux d'entre eux bruno et
véronique ils ont suivi leur regard leur
garde un vrai premier était début août
en région parisienne mais cela pourrait
être partout ailleurs en france des
façades d'immeubles bloc l'horizon de
milliers d'enfants dont les vacances
dérouleront entre le parking la rue et
l'escalier au troisième étage de cet
immeuble
véronique 7 ans et bruno quatre ans cet
été ils ont de la chance ils échapperont
un mois de garderie comme l'an dernier +
1 mois de colonies de vacances mauvais
souvenir leur mère a réussi à les
inscrire au secours populaire français
demain matin ils partiront passer quatre
semaines en hollande arrive des enfants
mon salaire est de 3000 environ par mois
je suis non tenues de faire appel à des
secours populaire organismes comme ça
pour que mes enfants comme les autres
profitent de vacances l'année
c'est le grand jour des cars venus de
toute la france ont rassemblé à paris
plus de 600 enfants tous ces enfants en
effet sélectionné par diverses instances
sociales bien sûr c'est une boutade en
lamelles 43% en france est de 5 à 14 ans
ne partent jamais en vacances c'est à
dire plus de 3 millions bruno n'avait
jamais pris train véronique à première
sa maman de bien veiller sur parfois
bien sûr les premiers instants sont
difficiles à passer
véronique et bruno ce soir 10 comme tout
le monde d'ailleurs
au bout d'une heure de voyage à peine
les jeux commencent deux heures plus
tard c'est la totale décontraction
à cet âge là c'est bien connu on dort
n'importe où
le train s'est déjà arrêtée dans
plusieurs gares hollandaise et 100 à
chaque fois quelques dizaines d'enfants
cette fois c'est au tour de nos deux
héros même scénario
la famille d'accueil est là et attend
qu'on la perd
la famille de nord très émues va
découvrir véronique et bruno
ils sont jeunes ils ont deux enfants à
peu près de l'âge de nos deux petits
français il habite près deux vols dans
le nord de la hollande
véronique sourit la première bruno
fatigué bousculait fait moins bonne
figure
monsieur et madame de nord en français
comme ils peuvent multiplie les phrases
apaisante
enfin ils se sont trouvés pour l'instant
c'est le principal
m
à brunehaut refuse la main tendue le
petit hollandais en maillot sombre va
hausser une épaule tout s'arrangera plus
tard
quelques minutes plus tard c'est
l'arrivée à la maison en pleine forêt
bruno ne fait pas la tête mais il est
fatigué mais s'est levé tôt ce matin la
maman hollandaise va bien trouver les
gestes et les mots qu'il faut ce soir
laissons les tranquilles
nous reviendrons demain matin un petit
déjeuner comme on en connaît pas en
france avec plein de bonnes choses
les familles hollandaises écrit six
enfants
bénévolement il y a des enfants sont en
situation difficile et nous pouvons
donner les enfants par contre et c'est
aussi pour
nos enfants n'ont intéressant ou
agréable d'avoir ici des oranges
étrangers oui la plupart des hollandais
habitent des maisons individuelles
conditions favorables pour recevoir des
enfants en vacances mais en plus
monsieur et madame de nore habitent tous
contre la forêt véronique et bruno
découvre ce qui va être leur terrain de
jeu pendant quatre semaines
ça y est les enfants plus de possession
de leur domaine et j'ajoute que l'an
prochain pour la première fois des
enfants hollandais viendront eux aussi
en france accueillis par des familles et
qu'on ne peut bien entendu que s'en
réjouir
football les trois surprise de la
deuxième journée du championnat le match
nul de saint-etienne hier soir sur son
terrain face à lille 0 0
un parc des princes comble en plein mois
d'août pour la belle victoire de paris
saint germain contre marseille 2 à 1
et puis la défaite de bordeaux contre
angers 3 0 une équipe bordelaise pas
tout à fait en forme être battu par
strasbourg champion de france soit mais
par la modeste équipe d'angers et sur le
score sans appel de 3 0
ces gratte pour une équipe qui affichait
cette année après un recrutement
impressionnant de hautes ambitions
angers a gagné facilement ce match et le
score aurait pu être plus lourd
c'est maroc qui marque le premier but
une frappe immédiate le second but va
être marquée dans quelques instants par
le même maroc l'a surpris aussi nos
caméraman d'ailleurs et le troisième but
sera marqué sur une erreur de défense
grossières de sa nouilles augustin va
servir félix près marqué sur le papier
bordeaux possède actuellement avec
solaire lacombe et guemriche mines
d'attac de valeur internationale
pourtant la fiche ne tient pas ce
qu'elle promet le public déçu risque de
délaisser le chemin du stade
deux semaines à peine après le début du
championnat bordeaux est en difficulté
vendredi prochain bordeaux devra donc
battre valenciennes pour reconquérir ses
supporters dépités mais une équipe dans
la moitié de l'effectif a été
bouleversée et est capable de retrouver
rapidement cohésion efficacité on ne
peut s'empêcher d'être sceptique
à l'issue de cette seconde journée de
championnat il n'y a plus que 5 équipes
comptant le maximum de points nantes
strasbourg difficile vainqueur de m
monaco nîmes et la surprenante équipe de
valenciennes saint-etienne qui a raté
son premier match à geoffroy guichard
alors que paris saint-germain reconquis
son public et puis en athlétisme des
records battus au championnat d'europe
qui ont lieu à turin
l'allemand de l'ouest schmidt a ravi aux
britanniques aimeraient le record
d'europe du 400 m haies en 47 secondes
85 centièmes et encore mieux l'allemande
de l'est marita corps a battu son propre
record du monde du 400 m plat
marita koch cours vie très vite à tel
point que 55 secondes suffisent pour
voir et relater son nouveau record du
monde prodigieuse petit allemands de
l'est qui en une semaine inscrit son nom
à deux reprises sur les tablettes du 400
m féminin
regardez elle court à l'extérieur et sa
domination est telle qu'elle semble
courir seul sans aucune difficulté
elle vole littéralement vers un succès
historique déjà dimanche dernier à
postdam
elle réalise un chronomètre de 48
secondes 89 centièmes améliorant son
propre record
une façon très personnelle de répondre à
sa rivale la soviétique push ou nova qui
vient de se signaler au spartak ya mais
aujourd'hui à turin il y à un peu plus
d'une heure vous le voyez sur ces images
elle pulvérise son propre record en 48
secondes 59 centièmes oui 48 secondes 59
centièmes marita coop sera sans nul
doute la première femme à descendre en
dessous des 48 secondes
bravo demain tiercé à deauville les
pronostics de pierre weil pirates bresse
qui je dis nous donner le tiercé dans le
désordre mais cette fois ci dans l'ordre
c'est sûr dans les pronostics
faut pas trop s'avancer alors qu'en est
il alors demain c'est sur l'hippodrome
de la touques qui porte le nom de la
rivière qui longe au champ de courses
que ce courant se tient fait justement
un pour ce qui a été choisie est un
handicap de 2000 mètres le prix des
chênes et et nous connaissons bien les
vingt chevaux qui composent le lot pour
les avoir vus courir déjà très souvent
cette année le choix n'est pas facile
pour autant si je préfère me fier aux
entraîneurs qui ont fait leurs preuves
dans les gros handicaps comme celui-ci
exemple philippe la lune qui espère une
victoire de les astres que
personnellement je placerais en tête des
pronostics dont le lie à bord d'une
distance un peu longue pour lui mais
bernard sécly pense qu'il peut tout à
fait le faire il en est de même pour
patrick biancone qui compte sur une
victoire lui aussi dedans scarlatti qui
est en super forme actuellement
rennes side cherche à gagner sa course
depuis longtemps et chacune hinton
junior pense que demain il aura de très
bonnes chances de pouvoir participer à
l'arrivée dirigeante porte un point
intéressant 49 kg il sera l'outsider
dangereux de cette épreuve acquis folle
vient de très bien courir à chantilly
handicap comme celui ci est tout à fait
à sa portée il pour terminer tard win
qui est un cheval un peu froid mais bien
soutenu et dans un bon jour il peut très
bien créer une surprise d'autant que sa
cote sera très élevé alors je vous
rappelle les numéros qu'ils porteront le
7 le neuf le 14 le 16 le vin le 3 et le
nom je me suis encore trompé le 7 le 9
et le 4 ensuite le fais le vin le 3 et
le 14 c'est ça et puis pirette antenne
de midi de lundi sera transmis depuis le
haras du pin alors ça ça va faire
plaisir aux amateurs de chevaux et oui
est d'autant que le haras du pin est le
plus important est certainement le plus
beau des haras nationaux
alors l'année dans le journal 13 heures
nous nous expliquerons en détail ce
qu'est un rat nationale et à quoi il
peut bien servir
mais tout de suite je peux vous
expliquer simplement ce qu'un nationale
et haras nationaux sont des dépôts des
talons et quelques fois qu'on aura du
pain d école nationale de formation pour
maréchaux ferrants palefrenier ou
techniciens supérieurs bien nationaux
aux dépens du ministère de la
peinture et ont pour mission d'orienter
les secteurs de l'élevage de
l'équitation et des courses bienvenue
verrons tout ça en détail donc lundi à
partir de 12h30 le tour de france à
voile oui le tour de france à voile
suite du carnet de bord dans régalé sur
le voilier d'antenne 2 nous en sommes
maintenant à l'avant dernière étape donc
de la première partie de la course
pourquoi
du soleil et du vent un temps rêvé pour
cette 10e étape du tour de france à la
voile la baule saint gilles croix de vie
en vendée
dès le départ le bateau marseille
prenait la tête de la régate pour la
conserver sur la ligne d'arrivée devant
brest l'étape courue aux allures
portantes c'est à dire avec un vent
soufflant sur l'arrière du bateau sous
cette allure les voiliers naviguent
presque toujours groupé et il est
difficile aux concurrents de creuser de
gros écarts
entraînés par leur spinnaker cette
grande voile d'avant multicolores la
conduite des voiliers demande beaucoup
d'attention à coups de barres malheureux
le résultat ne se fait pas attendre le
bateau se couche
autant de secondes perdues pour remettre
le voilier dans le droit chemin dans ce
tour de france à la voile en équipage un
peu différent des autres le bateau le
touquet cinq femmes à bord actuellement
classé 20e sur 25 concurrents en tant
qu'équipe acheminer ce qu'en font ses
concurrents ils sont très gentils avec
nous ils sont même un petit peu
condescendant on n'a pas fait des
résultats fabuleux
cela parce qu'on se bat pas d'ailleurs
mais apparemment il ya quelques petites
choses qui nous échappent encore
l'ambiance est bonne on se bagarre on se
bagarre depuis l'idée que le début on
espère encore grimper un petit peu à
saint gilles croix de vie l'escale des
bateaux devait être prolongée de 24
heures en effet un avis de coup de vent
a amené le comité de course à retarder
le départ une courte sortie du bateau
d'antenne 2 vous donne une idée de
l'état de la mer ce jour-là pour des
professionnels comme pour tous les
plaisanciers un évident que devant est
un effectivement il ne sert pas en
principe la transat en double
qui s'est passé récemment il ya eu un
avis de coup de vent ils ont retardé le
départ c'est une
c'est une règle ça n'est pas du tout une
question des professionnels ou pas on
n'a pas le droit d'aller casser un
bateau ou de se planquer sur les côtes
se protéger des professionnels ce matin
presque tous les équipages avaient envie
de partir mais mais il faut il faut
attendre et voir un petit peu ce qui se
passe ce serait de la tribune et de vin
est très fort qu'on n'est pas un
navigateur justement il faut prendre
conscience que la mer est dangereuse
dangereuse surtout à la proche des côtes
les bateaux modernes sont assez solides
pour résister face à une mer déchaînée
par contre le meilleur plastique ne
tient pas longtemps sur des rochers une
course comme le tour de france à la
voile est une régate côtière dans le
mauvais temps le risque encouru sont
supérieurs à une traversée de
l'atlantique
le soleil revenu les voiliers du tour de
france sont repartis pour la rochelle
l'étape du calme après la tempête peu de
vent mais encore de la houle
une traversée sans histoire toutefois et
sous les tours du vieux port de la
rochelle
une première victoire de cannes devant
menton et dunkerque
le bateau cannois est barré par yannick
paul est champion du monde de 420
classement général inchangé brest
toujours spi jaune devant marseille
reste maintenant à jeter un coup d'oeil
sur le temps demain coup d'oeil
sympathique puisque la météo annonce du
soleil et de la chaleur partout
cependant les nuages deviendront
abondance sur le bassin aquitain le sud
ouest du massif central les pyrénées et
le roussillon où des orages pourront
éclater en soirée les nuages rendront
visitent également à la bretagne
quelques pluies côtières sont possibles
fin de ce journal le prochain est à
23h10 avec bernard pradines haut avec
tous ceux qui ont préparé celui ci je
vous souhaite de passer vraiment une
excellente soirée à demain
à